la emisión promedio de los motores con
un nuevo diseño tiene que estar por
debajo de 20 partes por millón para que
el diseño cumpla con los nuevos
requerimientos sobre emisiones se
fabrican 10 motores con fines de prueba
y se mide el nivel de emisiones de cada
uno los datos de emisiones son y nos dan
los 10 datos de las emisiones uno para
cada motor llamé adelante y obtuve que
la media de la muestra es igual a 17.17
y la desviación estándar de esta muestra
de 10 datos es igual a 2.98 existe
suficiente evidencia basada en los datos
para concluir que este tipo de motor
cumple con el nuevo estándar supón que
estás dispuesto a tomar el riesgo de
error de tipo 1 con una probabilidad de
punto 0 1 y hablaremos de esto en unos
momentos pero antes establezcamos cuáles
serán nuestra hipótesis nula y nuestro y
potes alternativa nuestra hipótesis nula
sería que simplemente no cumplimos con
el estándar es decir la hipótesis nula
es que la media y las emisiones de
nuestros nuevos motores es exactamente
20 partes por millón básicamente lo que
queremos aquí es el mejor valor posible
o el menor valor posible donde aún no se
cumple con el estándar
y la hipótesis alternativa la hipótesis
alternativa es no si cumplimos con el
estándar y la verdadera media en estos
nuevos motores es menor a 20 partes por
millón y para ver que los datos que
tenemos son suficientes lo que vamos a
hacer es suponer que la hipótesis nula
es verdadera vamos a suponer
que es verdadera y suponiendo que esta
es verdadera dado que esta es verdadera
y que la probabilidad de que ocurra esto
la probabilidad de que la media de la
muestra sea menor a 1%
rechazaremos la hipótesis nula entonces
rechazaremos rechazaremos la hipótesis
nula sí
la probabilidad de que la media la
muestra es igual a 17.17 dado que la
hipótesis nula es verdadera es menor a
1% y observa si lo hacemos así tenemos
una probabilidad menor a 1% de que
tengamos un error de tipo 1 un error de
tipo 1 es que la rechazamos siendo
verdadera aquí hay tan sólo un 1% o
menos de un 1% que la rechazamos siendo
verdadera lo siguiente que tenemos que
considerar es con qué tipo de
distribución vamos a trabajar y lo
primero que me viene a la mente es que
aquí tan solo tenemos 10 muestras el
tamaño de muestra es igual a 10 es un
tamaño de muestra realmente pequeño por
lo cual trabajaremos con la distribución
y la estadística te planteado esto vamos
a calcularlo de la siguiente manera
podemos calcular la estadística te
basado en nuestros datos aquí arriba
esto va a ser igual
a la media de la muestra 17.17 menos la
media de la población que es 20 partes
por millón
todo esto dividido entre la desviación
estándar de la muestra que es 2.98 este
es realmente la definición del
estadístico t y esperemos que se vea que
viene del puntaje z y la distribución t
es una versión derivada de la
instrucción normal
usando el estadístico de 2.98 dividido
entre la raíz cola del tamaño de muestra
tenemos una muestra de 10 entonces es
dividido entre la raíz de 10 entonces
este valor es igual a déjame sacar la
calculadora para obtener este valor
entonces va a ser 17.17 -20 entre
paréntesis
/ 2.48 entre la raíz no eso no es lo que
quiero yo quiero la raíz cuadrada entre
la raíz cuadrada de 10
cierro paréntesis casi exactamente menos
3 entonces el estadístico te va a ser
igual esto es igual a menos 3.000 y lo
que tenemos que calcular como los
estadísticos te sigue una distribución t
así que tenemos que calcular cuál la
probabilidad de obtener un estadístico t
o un valor t que es menor o igual a este
valor es esto menor a 1%
en la manera ver esto es viendo la
distribución t supongamos que aquí
tenemos una distribución t normalizada
la distribución de todos los
estadísticos t será una distribución t
normalizada aquí tenemos la media de la
distribución t y va a haber un valor
crítico va a haber un valor crítico de t
aquí lo ponemos este sería un valor
crítico de t crítico nuestra tan fácil
escribir lo mejor lo va a hacer este
sería este de aquí sería un valor
crítico de t y queremos un valor crítico
de t de tal manera que la probabilidad
de obtener un valor de t menor a ese
valor crítico es menor a 1 por ciento la
probabilidad tiene un valor menor a este
es uno por ciento el valor de esta área
en amarillo es 1%
tenemos que buscar entonces ese valor
crítico ese valor que con una
distribución t
que tiene una n igual a 10 y 10 menos
uno igual a 9 grados de libertad y cuál
es este valor crítico nota que esta es
una distribución de un solo lado
entonces y aquí tenemos un 1%
esta parte restante vamos a tener 99%
ahora la mayoría de las tablas te están
orientadas para el otro lado nosotros
estamos un valor negativo pero la mayor
las tablas te te dan un valor positivo
entonces la manera como operan las
tablas te y aquí tengo una tabla t que
vamos usar en los momentos tu tienes tu
distribución de esta manera la tabla te
va a dar un valor crítico por acá por el
lado positivo donde la probabilidad de
obtener un valor t por arriba de ese
valor crítico es igual a 1 por ciento
mientras que la probable a obtener un
valor t por abajo de ese valor crítico
es igual a 99 % y como puedes ver bueno
sabemos que la distribución es simétrica
alrededor de la media entonces aquí
tenemos un valor positivo digamos un
valor de 2 entonces este valor va a ser
menos 2 teniendo en cuenta eso las
tablas t nos ayudan a calcular ese valor
entonces encontremos el valor de t
debajo del cual la probabilidad de
obtener un valor t es
99% de nueva cuenta recordemos que
estamos en una distribución bueno más
bien una situación de una sola cola
busquemos entonces nuestro valor crítico
es una situación de una sola cola esta
tabla la he tomado de wikipedia
queremos un valor acumulado de 99% aquí
tenemos 99% tenemos 9 grados de libertad
tenemos 10 datos 10 menos uno es 99
grados de libertad y aquí tenemos
nuestro valor crítico nuestro valor
crítico aquí es 2.821 y aquí simplemente
le cambiamos el signo lo invertimos y
aquí sería menos 2.821 entonces esto nos
dice que la probabilidad de obtener un
valor t menor que menos 2.821 va a ser
1% ahora nosotros tenemos un valor de t
que es ligeramente menor a ese nuestro
valor del estadístico t que es menos 3
va a estar por aquí aquí va a estar
nuestro estadístico de d
el cual definitivamente cae en lo que
podríamos llamar creo que le podíamos
llamar nuestra zona de rechazo y este
valor este valor de menos 3 es aún menos
probable del 1% inclusive podríamos
calcular el valor de esta área la
probabilidad de obtener un estadístico
de menor que menos 3 la cual es menor
que 1 % es un subconjunto de esta región
en amarillo ahora debido a que la
probabilidad de obtener un estadístico t
como el que obtuvimos es menor que 1 %
podemos con confianza rechazar la
hipótesis nula podemos con confianza
rechazar la hipótesis nula y por tanto
sentir que es tipo test alternativa es
la adecuada es la adecuada estamos
cumpliendo con el estándar de las
emisiones y sabemos que tenemos una
probabilidad menor a 1% de incurrir en
un error de tipo 1 bajo estas
circunstancias